wat ik altijd 1 hele leuke vraag vind in management
coaching is de
hoe krijg ik nou mijn team meer initiatiefrijk
wat heel veel leidinggevenden
zich helemaal niet realiseren
is dat als 1 team geen initiatief neemt
dat 9 van de 10 keer te maken
heeft met je eigen stijl van leidinggeven
die is dan waarschijnlijk heel sturend en inspirerend
en daarmee nemen eigenlijk het initiatief
bij het team weg
want ze moeten alles wat ze doen
moeten ze langs jou laten gaan
als je ervoor wilt zorgen dat 1 team meer initiatief
neemt en meer taakvolwassen wordt
dan is het heel belangrijk om 1 meer coachende
begeleidende leiderschapsstijl te hanteren
je legt ze niet uit hoe ze dingen moeten doen
je kijkt naar
hoe kan ik je begeleiden om De Dingen zo goed mogelijk
te doen maar hoe ze het doen en wat ze doen
dat laat je aan hen